a whole bunch of people have emailed me
saying David you've got to get a look at
this contract with the American voter
that Donald Trump has released for his
first hundred day action plan I want to
look at a few pieces of it because it is
absolutely insane we're gonna look just
at some of it it's a two-page document
we're linking to it on our youtube
channel and you can check it out let's
start with Donald Trump's six measures
to clean up Washington DC and I'll show
you just how insane this is so we're
focusing in on this piece of this
two-page document all right let's go
through it one by one
number one Trump in his first hundred
days will propose a constitutional
amendment to impose term limits on all
members of Congress I actually agree
with that but note the wording he will
propose one it will not happen second a
hiring freeze on federal employees to
reduce the federal workforce through
attrition this likely won't happen once
somebody explains to Trump how things
work in the real world remember that
government job jobs have already
declined under President Obama and this
is sort of an irrelevant dog whistle
number three in Trump's action plan a
requirement that for every new federal
regulation to existing regulations must
be a limited eliminated this is
impossible I mean this is just not how
government works you'll notice the term
requirement is there legally requirement
is a very very vague term is that an
executive order is that a bill what is a
requirement and when you're passing new
regulations or new laws there's really
no legal way to make requirements to
eliminate unrelated regulations I mean
it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever
number four Donald Trump promises in his
first hundred 200 days a five-year ban
on White House and congressional
officials becoming lobbyists after they
leave government service that I actually
like I I think that that would be great
I I don't know that that's actually
going to happen but it would be a really
really great thing number five a
lifetime ban on White House officials
lobbying on behalf of a foreign
government that I actually like also I
just don't think Trump's going to be
able to get it done and sixth a complete
ban on foreign lobbyists raising money
for American elections very difficult to
implement
especially given campaign
and slaw and Citizens United I sort of
like the idea of of the proposal but
with citizens united and so much of what
we now have in place for campaign
finance you can't possibly do that and
even though both houses of Congress will
be on Donald Trump's side Republican
Party in both sides of the Congress
why would they vote to limit their own
power it just doesn't make any sense
it's very hard to get people who had a
system get them into power want to
change the system that got them into
power let's look at a Cal ittle bit more
of this this is from Trump's and illegal
immigration Act let's then now we're
really getting into the meat of it this
according to Trump will fully fund the
construction of a wall on our southern
border with the full understanding that
the country of Mexico will be
reimbursing the United States for the
cost of the wall not happening Mexico
said it's not happening there's no legal
mechanism to ensure that that's going to
happen Mexico is not paying for the wall
it will also establish a two-year
mandatory minimum federal prison
sentence for illegally re-entering the
u.s. after a deportation a five-year
minimum federal prison sentence for
illegally re-entering for those with
felony convictions and also it will make
it that it open jobs must be offered to
American workers first so Mexico's not
refunding anything it's very clear some
of these additional sentences that Trump
is promising criminal sentences could be
passed I don't know if it could be done
with it a hundred days and this whole
thing of jobs must be offered to
American workers first for the most part
that's what the law already says if you
want to hire someone from another
country and bring them in and give them
legal status you actually have to go
through a pretty rigorous process of
proving that there's that you've really
looked for people in the US and didn't
find anybody it's called a something
like an extraordinary ability of
mechanism and I know some people who
have come to the US under that but this
idea of the whole offering of jobs I
just think this is so pie in the sky Pat
it is so unrealistic and when you look
at the wording you realize that much of
this means nothing it's not even a
specific proposal and this comes from a
guy who had illegal immigrants from
Poland working in his building so he's
the last person to make this case these
are mostly
dog whistles and meaningless red meat
and it's a two page document take a look
at it one provision is funnier than the
last and it really makes for some nice
reading it's if you were gonna I don't
know look at some comic books or
something this would be something
equivalent because it is just so insane
and will be believe me we will be
covering whether the promises are kept
already breaking the promise of being a
Washington outsider as I told you
earlier in the show hiring the usual
suspects lobbying firms to handle the
Trump transition